l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première question va
être posée par Monsieur Yann Bouard pour
le groupe les
républicain merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances mercredi
dernier lors de sa conférence de presse
le président de la République a
longuement évoqué nos compatriotes qui
gagn déjà trop pour être aidé et pas
assez pour bien vivre la France
populaire la France des classes moyennes
c'est qui dit qu'on vous proposez
quelque chose ce n'est jamais pour moi
et pourtant c'est celle qui tient le
pays le constat est juste mais il aura
fallu 7 ans au président pour comprendre
le drame que connaît notre pays
l'impossibilité pour les Français qui
travaillent dur de vivre correctement de
faire vivre décemment leur famille grâce
au revenus de leur travail 7 ans pour se
rendre compte que dans notre pays il y a
des millions de Français qui ne vivent
pas mieux en travaillant que s'il
restaiit à la maison 7 ans d'aveuglement
et bien souvent de mépris pour la
majorité silencieuse ces Français qui
tiennent le pays sont assommés par
l'inflation galopante chacun sen rend
compte en remplissant son cadit de
course ou son réservoir de carburant les
produits de grande consommation
alimentaire ces produits essentiels ont
augmenté de 24,8 % depuis janvier 2022
comme le révèle l'FC Que Choisir et ce
n'est pas fini car en ce début d'année
le gouvernement a décidé d'aggraver les
choses avec une nouvelle taxe infligée
aux Français la hausse de 9,8 % du prix
de l'électricité lorsque l'on gouverne
il y a la parole mais il y a surtout les
actes vous prétendez vouloir protéger
les classes moyennes dans les fait vous
réinstaurez la taxe sur la consommation
finale de l'électricité alors que les
Français n'ont jamais été autant en
difficulté alors que les Français ont
multiplié les efforts pour diminuer leur
consommation électrique leur factur
énergétiques n'auront jamais été aussi
élevé c'est le résultat de décision
politique grave celle de votre
gouvernement alors Monsieur le Ministre
comptez-vous enfin prendre conscience
des difficultés de ces millions de
Français êtes-vous prêt à annuler cette
C hausse scandaleuse du prix de
l'électricité qu'allez-vous faire
concrètement pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et pour passer de
la parole aux
actes merci beaucoup monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Prisc t ministre
en charge du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député pour répondre à votre
question le ministre de l'économie est
en déplacement avec le président de la
République cet agenda était connu de
tous et donc je me permets de le
rappeler ici et de vous répondre sur ce
sujet extrêmement important si vous le
permettez dès le début de la crise avec
la majorité présidentielle nous avons
protégé les Français avec la mise en
place d'un pouglier tarifaire pour
éviter justement au français une Hauses
massives de factures qu' connu tous nos
voisins européens en 2022 et en 2023
sans l'action du gouvernement le tarif
réglementé de vente d'électricité aurait
doublé l'État a pris en charge de façon
sont assez évident plus de la moitié de
la facture des Français et nous
continuons à agir massivement sur le
prix de l'électricité en 2024 avec le
maintien de la taxe sur l'électricité en
dessous de son niveau de pré-crise avec
le maintien du chèque énergie pour les
ménages les plus fragiles avec le
maintien de l'amortisseur électricité du
plafond du prix pour les TPE et des
aides pour les entreprises ayant signé
des contrats au pire moment de la crise
nous agissons aussi sur le long terme
pour que les les prix reste durablement
les moins chers en Europe comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui avec la relance de la
production nucléaire la hausse de la
production renouvelable le plan sobriété
la réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité je vois que visiblement
ces sujets ne vous intéressent que trop
peu je viens de répondre à votre
question qui visiblement ne vous
intéresse pas mais peut-être aviez-vous
une peut-être aviez-vous une question
pour vos collègues sénateurs qui sont
majoritairement là-bas de votre famille
politique peut-être pourriez-vous les
interroger sur la raison pour laquelle
ils ont demandé lors du projet de loi de
financeces de rétablir massivement et
brutalement la fin du bouclier tarifaire
et nous serions au 1er septembre au 1er
février avec cet amendement qui a été
rejeté à pas 8 % d'augmentation mais
bien 15 % d'augmentation désolé de pas
avoir pu être plus entendu mais je pense
que la prochaine fois ça sera important
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
bouca merci la présidente 10 %
d'augmentation d'électricité 1,14 %
d'augmentation du SMIC voilà vos AC la
France qui
travaille je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Anne leenav pour le groupe
horizon merci merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires depuis le
1er janvier 2024 le dispositif d'aide
aux travaux de rénovation énergétique ma
primime renove bénéficie d'une enveloppe
de 1,6 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
mais comporte surtout de nouvelles
règles plus contraignantes les quelles
sont sources d'inquiétude pour de
nombreux artisans et petites entreprises
du bâtiment cette actualisation
s'inscrit dans la volonté du
gouvernement d'accélérer la transition
énergétique des logements en favorisant
les travaux d'ampleur de rénovation cela
se traduit par un recentrage des aides
sur des bouquets de rénovation en vue
d'atteindre 200000 rénovations globales
en 2024 cependant les associations et
fédérations d'artisans et de petites
entreprises du bâtiment que j'ai
récemment rencontré dans ma circonsr
redoute les conséquences tout d'abord
les rénovations les rénovations globales
sont très contraignantes pour les
logements occupés les reste à charge
important compte tenu du montant des
travaux mais ce qui inquiète le plus ce
sont les nouvelles obligations pour les
entrepris pouvant mener les travaux en
effet l'entreprise doit désormais être
certifiée RGE reconnu garant de
l'environnement il s'agit d'un agrément
complexe à obtenir surtout pour les
petites structures ainsi il craignent
que les grands groupes à dimension
régionale voire nationale soient
favorisés sur le marché à leur détriment
dans un contexte de marché déjà
difficile pour ces entreprises ils ont
adressé un courrier à l'ancienne
Première ministre madame ellisabeth
borne afin de l'alerter sur cette
situation et faire des propositions
alternatives concrètes afin de ne pas
exclure les 600000 artisans et PME
concernés sur nos territoires par
exemple à la place de la certification
RGE de l'entreprise il propose qu'une
fois les travaux effectués par
l'entreprise une certification de fin de
chantier viennent attester de la
conformité des travaux ainsi Monsieur le
Ministre quels éléments pouvez-vous nous
apporter et notamment à ces artisans
afin de lever leurs inquiétudes je vous
remercie merci ma cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires merci madame la présidente
madame la députée
Anne
les bâtiments c'est 20 % de nos
émissions faire en sorte qu'on soit
capable de mieux les rénover de mieux
les isoler c'est à la fois bon pour la
planète pour limiter nos émissions bon
pour le pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui sont
à l'intérieur avec vous le savez un
angle particulier pour les passoirs
thermiques ce que vous évoquez c'est les
modifications qui sont intervenues il y
a quelques jours avec un double objectif
continuer à massifier le nombre de
rénovation énergétique et d'autre part
faire en sorte d'améliorer pas seulement
le nombre mais la qualité des
rénovations qui sont conduites pour
faire simple
c'est 700000 rénovations par an c'est
une multiplication par 10 grâce au
dispositif mapre Renov par rapport à ce
qui existait auparavant mais dans ces
700000 le nombre de rénovation
performantes n'est pas assez important
par rapport à ce que sont nos objectifs
les deux nouveaux piliers efficacité et
performance qui se sont mis en place au
1er janvier vise à faire en sorte qu'on
aille vers davantage de Renault
performant en particulier par la
systématisation de mon accompagnateur
Renov vous évoquez le courrier du
président de la CAPEB non seulement ce
courrier a retenu notre attention il a à
la fois retenu mon attention en qualité
de ministre mais il a également retenu
l'attention du nouveau Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal dans un contexte où les
propos du président de la République sur
la nécessité d'aller vers des
simplifications trouve un écho par
rapport à une partie de ces nouveaux
dispositifs vous évoquez la question en
particulier des groupements momentanés
d'entreprises qui sont un moyen pour les
artisans de pouvoir répondre de manière
collective et éviter de laisser le
marché au grand groupe vous évitez les
pistes éventuelles de simplification RGE
ce que je suis capable de vous dire et
je dirais même mieux de vous
annoncer c'est que dans le courant du
mois de
février je vais réunir à rocklore un
comité de suivi de la rénovation
énergétique avec l'ensemble des force
viv et notamment les artisans pour
regarder ce que nous pouvons simplifier
et la façon dont tout en continuant à
garder le rythme sur la transition
écologique nous pourons faciliter la vie
de ceux que ça
concerne merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Jordan
Guitton pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur je tiens d'abord à saluer le
travail remarquable de nos forces de
l'ordre qui œuvre chaque jour à la
protection des Français le chaos
sécuritaire s'accentue toujours plus
avec des chiffres vertigineux en 2023
1000 agressions par jour le chaos
sécuritaire tue jusqu'aux agriculteurs
qui qui manifeste légitimement et à qui
je veux aussi rendre hommage ici la
délinquance se répand jusqu'au plus
petit des villages dans mon département
de l'Aube les cambrillages ont explosé
de 200 % fin 2023 il y a 2 jours encore
un tabac se faisait braquer à bar surobe
dans mon territoire cette insécurité est
un véritable fléo qui menace les
Français qui travaillent chaque jour et
se voit voler leur bien et leur intimité
c'est le résultat de votre politique
laxiste du pont Moretti d'
même constat même échec rien ne change
en guise de remerciement vous avez été
reconduit dans vos ministères c'est ce
qu'on appelle la prime à l'incompétence
votre volonté politique est nulle
combien d'individus sont trop vite
relâchés et passe plus de jours à
récidiver que de jours en prison en
vérité la peur doit changer de camp
d'ailleurs monsieur Darmanin vous dites
aimer terminer le travail commencé mais
vous n'avez rien commencé les oigation
de quitter le territoire français 9/ 10
ne sont pas appliqués et nous mettent en
danger nous l' avons vu encore hier la
lutte contre les agressions il y en a
une toutes les 44 secondes l'expulsion
des clandestins ils sont presque 1
million sur notre territoire selon votre
ministère alors monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur avait trahi sa famille
politique en 2017 en disant rejoindre le
candidat du vide aujourd'hui le vide
c'est l'ensemble de votre gouvernement
ma question est simple allez-vous enfin
commencer quelque chose pour protéger
les Français
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Marie Lebec ministre
en charge des relations avec le
Parlement merci Madame la la présidente
monsieur le député Jordane Guiton je
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser
l'absence de monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur général d'manin et peut-être
pour apporter une réponse à votre
question qui somme toute était une mise
en accusation du gouvernement vous
rappelez que pour le point que vous avez
soulevé concernant votre département de
l'eau la lutte contre le cambriolage qui
est la une des priorités fixées par le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outrm a considérablement c'est
considérablement amélioré grâce à la
mobilisation exceptionnelle des
policiers des gendarmes et des
magistrats et que grâce à cette
mobilisation nous avons réussi à
inverser la tendance pour être très
factuel alors que en 2022 les
cambriolages étaient en très forte
hausse de 11 % l'année dernière la
hausse n'était plus que de 3 % mais
surtout les derniers mois de l'année 202
23 les cambriolages ont diminué puisque
le total du dernier trimestre est en
baisse de 2 % par rapport au trimestre
précédent il faut reconnaître cet effort
important à nos policiers et nos
gendarmes dans les départements qui ont
bénéficié en septembre 2022 de la mise
en place du plan national de
sécurisation renforcé les les
cambriolages sont en baisse alors qu'ils
augmentaient fortement en 2022 les 20
départements concernés sur les 12
derniers mois les cambriolages de
logement sont donc en baisse je prends
quelques exemples symboliques
emblématiques de cette lutte je pense
notamment au département des Bouches du
rô avec - 6 % la Loire Atlantique - 14 %
le rô - 20 % et en ce qui concerne Paris
et sa petite couronne il y a une baisse
de -1 % c'est encore insuffisant mais
nous y travaillons dans votre
département plus spécifiquement dans
l'Aube entre 2017 et 2022 les
cambriolages de logement ont diminué de
- 6 % et ceci a été rendu notamment
possible grâce à la hausse des effectif
de plus de 4 % de la ddpn entre 2017 et
2023 qui est notamment le résultat des
décisions prises dans le cadre de la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur outre les actions pour
lutter plus efficacement contre les
cambriolages je pense notamment au
recrutement massif d'effectif la
création de nouvelles unités de force
mobilees de gendarmerie les 239 unités
de brigade de gendarmerie permett de
continuer merci
beaucoup monsieur le député madame la
ministre par votre réponse on comprend
donc en fait que c'est une baisse de la
Haus donc la ha continue c'est votre
bilan qui est calamiteux en terme
sécuritaire les Français vous
sanctionneront dans les urnes le 9 juin
prochain je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Édouard Benard pour le groupe
GDR merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances celui-ci a annoncé ce
dimanche une hausse des tarifs
réglementés de vente d'électricité au
1er février de + 8,6 % pour le tarif de
base à + 9,8 % pour pour les usagers en
heure creuse alors même que les prix de
gros de l'électricité ont baissé de 30 %
sur le dernier semestre cette
augmentation tient de la seule volonté
de votre gouvernement qui a décidé de
relever la taxe intérieure sur la
consommation finale d'électricité depuis
2022 les Français ont vu leur facture
d'électricité flamber de 43 % 43 % alors
que l'électricité consommée en France
très largement décarboné et quoi qu'on
en dise peu dépendante des alléas
géopolitiques qui affectent les cou des
énergies fossiles tandis que 12 millions
de nos concitoyens sont déjà confrontés
à la précarité énergétique cette
nouvelle hausse relève du raquette P et
simple les récents travaux réalisés par
le conseil social et économique central
de DF démontrent qu'une réforme du
calcul des tarifs réglementés reprenant
simplement les principes de péréquation
tarifaire et d'empilement des coûts de
production permettrai à elle seul de
réduire les factures des usagers de 20 %
tout en finançant les six nouvelles
tranches pr que vous appelez de vos vœux
ou des investissements massifs
d'amélioration des performances
énergétiques de l'habitat que j'appelle
des miens l'échec de la libéralisation
du marché européen de l'énergie est
patent sa réforme actée le 17 octobre
n'y changera rien alors monsieur le
ministre je vous demande avec mon groupe
et au nom des millions de Français qui
se serrent déjà la ceinture de renoncer
à cette hausse irresponsable et
d'engager le chantier d'une reprise en
main publique de ce bien vital je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
[Musique]
c'est
parfait la parole est à Madame frisc
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
en charge du renouveau
démocratique merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Benard pardon
tout d'abord permettez-moi de saluer
votre arrivée de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue dans cette belle institution
dans ce bel
hémicycle où nous avons plaisir à
débattre toujours des idées et à faire
avancer le débat politique et public
pour effectivement non pas quelques égau
chagrin mais bien pour les Françaises et
les Français sur des sujets majeurs dont
je vous remercie vous parlez aujourd'hui
essentiellement il s'agit en d'autres
terme du pouvoir d'achat car oui le
pouvoir d'achat est un enjeu de
préoccupation et un défi auquel la
majorité présidentielle et le
Gouvernement s'attache à répondre avec
un certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
mises en place notamment dè le nouveau
quinquena qui s'est ouvert en 2022 avec
le vote de pack pouvoir d'achat la
revalorisation des retraites mais
également la suppression d'un certain
nombre de taxes comme la poursuite de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle la baisse de la pression
fiscale notamment sur les premières
tranches de l'impôt sur le revenu enfin
bref la liste pourrait être longue mais
cela je tiens à vous le dire parce que
vous n'avait peut-être pas l'historique
tout cela a été permis grâce à cette
majorité présidentielle parce que oui
nous avons permis de faire voter ces
mesures concrètes pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français malgré un certain
nombre d'autres députés je tiens vous le
dire aussi attention certains de vos
collègues ici sur ces bancs non de
gauche non de gauche que leur place dans
l'hémicycle je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Christian Baptiste pour le groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente Mesdames
monsieur les ministre chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Atal Premier ministre et ex-ministre de
l'éducation nationale au moment des
faits que je vais évoquer la veille de
votre nomination à Matignon le journal
médiap a révélé que l'enquête
administrative annoncée dans la foulée
du suicide du jeune Lucas 13 ans n'a
jamais eu lieu et que celle menée par le
parquet a été baclée interrogé fin 2023
monsieur Atal désormais Premier ministre
n'a jamais voulu répondre et c'est pour
cela que je viens reposer la question
devant la représentation nationale à
l'époque l'émotion était vive et la
déclarations unanimes des anciens
ministres papend à Marlin Chapa en
passant par clébonne tous et toutes tous
et toutes expriment leur sidération
derrière l'émotion suscité par ce drame
survenu en janvier l'année dernière rien
n'a été fait pour savoir si le collège
de l'adolescent aurait pu prévenir ce
suicide l'enquête administrative
annoncée et enterrée par le principal et
et et le principal de l'établissement
qui minimise les fait de harcèlement n'a
jamais été auditionné l'homophobie
l'attente dont était victime le cas
était en réalité omniprésente dans
l'établissement depuis son arrivée le
principal de l'établissement a-t-il
tenté de préserver la réputation du
collège qui Ta livré de fauses
informations ou a minimiser les
agissements des élèves mis en cause
malheureusement rien n'a été fait pour
poursuivre les coupables ma question
pourquoi cette enquête annoncée par le
gouvernement n'a jamais été lancée
pourquoi avoir communiqué sur une
enquête administrative qui n'a jamais
existé et oui très
bien je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Amélie ouea
Castera ministre en charge de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports et des Jeux paralympiques madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés mesdames monsieur le député
Baptiste une école qui ne transige
jamais sur le respect de l'enfant et
s'oppose catégoriquement au harcèlement
pas plus qu'un enseignant un enfant ne
doit avoir peur à l'école il doit s'y
sentir bien vous évoquez le cas de Lucas
je veux plus largement évoquer ceux de
lins de Nicola avoir une pensée pour
toutes les familles de victimes depuis 6
ans vous le savez on a considérablement
renforcé notre action contre le
harcèlement notamment avec la loi portée
par le député balanan qui en fait un
délit et avec la mise en place du
programme pH le Premier ministre l'a
impulsé en mettant fin à cette are du
pas de vague il nous a donné la feuille
de route 100 % prévention 100 %
détection 100 % solution l de la journée
non au harcèlement 7 millions d'élèves
du CE2 à la terminale ont répondu à un
questionnaire pour déceler les
situations de harcèlement et de mal-être
à l'école dans quelques jours nous
aurons la synthèse détaillée de cette
démarche qui est inédite et je
communiquerai une photographie qui est
claire qui est précise de où nous en
sommes dans les écoles et les
établissements ainsi que sur toutes les
enquêtes en cours les équipes éducatives
sont extrêmement mobilisées le ministère
les a armé au niveau des département des
académies en déployant notamment 150
postes de responsabl nous allons avancer
aider les parents d'élèves aussi à mieux
détecter les situations de harcèlement
aucune situation ne doit rester sans
réponse tant pour les élèves victimes
que pour les élèves hauteur que nous
pouvons désormais changer d'école y
compris dans le primaire l'école de la
République est une école qui doit
protéger qui rend heureux et il n'y aura
aucune exception à ce principe je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame m la
ministre monsieur le député madame
madame la ministre beaucoup d' fait
d'annonce mais très peu d'actes par
cette question je m'associe à la pleine
à la peine des parents de Nicolas jeune
guadeloupéen qui s'est suicidé à poiss
dans les ivelines après s'être plein
l'année précédente de harcèlement mais
aussi des parents de Dina qui a mis fin
à ses jours après des faits similaires
au collège Émile Zola à kinc
merci merci beaucoup mon cher collègu la
parole est à Monsieur David Valence pour
le groupe
Renaissance madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre les
Français ont envie de train et ils le
montrent l'année 2023 a battu tous les
records en la matière plus 8 % de
fréquentation pour le TER plus 4 % pour
le TGV à rebours de certaines idées
reçues nos concitoyens n'opposent pas
les trains du quotidien et la grande
vitesse ils les perçoivent à juste titre
comme complémentair et leur exence
vis-à-vis de la SNCF est à la mesure de
leur attachement affectif à l'opérateur
ferroviaire historique or un quotidien
du matin s fait hier l'éco de réflexion
interne au groupes public ferroviaire
concernant des lignes déficitaires ces
réflexions faisaient état de plusieurs
choix soit la nécessité de solliciter
des contributions des collectivités
territoriales pour équilibrer les
comptes de ces lignes déficitaires soit
la nécessité de faire évoluer leurs
dessertes voir tout simplement de les
supprimer précisons qu'une ligne
ficitaire n'est pas forcément une ligne
qui est peu fréquentée ce peut-être une
ligne où les abonnés sont majoritaires
et plus important que les occasionnels
des desserts comme Chamberry comme La
Rochelle comme laaval comme Charleville
Maisière comme Épinal ou comme
saint-diier desvuges serait visé SNCF
voyageur a tenu hier à démentir ses
propos monsieur le ministre je suis né
en 1981 année de lancement du TGV par le
président François mitteran pouvez-vous
nous confirmer que regarde toujours le
train à grande vitesse comme un outil
d'aménagement du territoire et que la
péréquation restera bien la règle pour
TGV entre les lignes bénéficiaires et
les lignes déficitaires je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président Valence y a-t-il
des projets de suppression de ligne TGV
à
l'étude la réponse est non y a-t-il des
projets de diminution de fréquence sur
des lignes TGV existantes la réponse est
non de façon extrêmement claire non
seulement SNCF voyageur a démenti mais
je suis en mesure de le faire de la
façon la plus solennelle il n'y a aucune
diminution de service sur les lignes TGV
qui soit
étude maintenant ça n'est pas seulement
au députés que je m'adresse c'est au
président du comité d'orientation des
infrastructure vous êtes né en 81 que
marque cette décennie cette décennie
marque le moment où notre pays et on
peut à certains égards sans enorgueillir
a fait le choix des lignes à grande
vitesse mais dans le même temps le
financement des LGV c'est fait en
diminuant la régénération des petites
lignes tout l'enjeu pour nous
aujourd'hui il est de tenir dans un même
mouvement la poursuite de la grande
vitesse et l'accentuation de la
régénération qui génère ou qui entraîne
compte tenu du sous-investissement des
retards considérables qui font parfois
la une de la presse et qui ne font pas
honneur à notre groupe et à la SNCF et
plus largement aux conditions
désenclavement du territoire j'aurai
l'occasion vendredi de recevoir le
président farandou pour faire un point
extrêmement précis avec lui notamment
sur les dysfonctionnements inacceptable
et répété sur la ligne qui va à cler
Montferrand et ça n'est pas la seule sur
lequel nous aurons l'occasion d'avancer
je veux redire que les annonces de la
première ministre qui seront mis en uvre
par ce gouvernement c'est 100 milliards
d'euros pour le ferroviaire d'ici 2040
et c'est 1 milliard d'euros de plus à la
fin du quinena sur la régénération des
petites lignes pour tenir les
engagements du Président de la
République sur les train du
quotidien merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député merci
Monsieur minist minist d'avoir rappelé
que l'État est décidé à jouer son rôle
d'actionnaire de l'entreprise publique
et à lui passer des consignes claires en
matière d'offre de transport mais aussi
en terme d'investissement merci merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame André
Torenia pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre des Affaires
étrangères 10000 enfants tués 24000
morts des milliers sous les décambbres
600 blessés des centaines de centres de
soins bombardés 70000 maisons rasées 1,9
9 millions de personnes déplacées voici
le bilan de plus de 100 jours de
massacre de masse la population affamée
de Gaza survie au milieu de flaqu d'eau
usé qui débordent des égoutûts détruits
la maladie s'abat sur ce petit bout de
territoire martyre tuant tuant toujours
plus pas de cesser le feu à l'horizon
pour une paix juste et durable le droit
des peuples à disposer deeux même reste
notre boussole qu'elle prenne la forme
d'une solution à deux états d'un état
plurinational ou d'une autre ution
viable mutuellement acceptée permettra
de sortir de ce statut qu plus mortifère
que jamais mais néaniaou persiste mon
insistance dit-il est ce qui a empêché
au fil des ans la création d'un État
palestinien qui aurait constitué un
danger existentiel pour Israël vous avez
qualifié d'inquiétante cette déclaration
la semaine dernière vous discréditiez la
démarche de l'Afrique du Sud de
poursuivre Israël pour génocide devant
la cour international de justice
aujourd'hui vous semblez découvrir la
duplicité de ces dirigeants qui sabotent
le processus de paix depuis des
décennies en avril 2017 le candidat
Macron s'engageait à mettre toute son
énergie pour la paix et la
reconnaissance de deux États qui
cohabite il promettait de condamner les
politiques de colonisation monsieur le
ministre 10 ans après la résolution
votée par l'Assemblée nationale la
France va-t-elle enfin emboîer le pas du
candidat Macron et reconnaître
l'existence de l'État palestinien comme
vous-même le préconisiez hier devant le
Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Prisc EV
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
en charge de renouveau
démocratique merci merci madame la
présidente madame la députée avant de
répondre à votre question je veux
excuser le Ministre en charge qui
présidait hier le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies précisément sur la
question que vous posez aujourd'hui
cette réunion confirme la priorité
donnée par la France à mettre un terme
au combat que le Hamas a déclenché le 7
octobre par ses attaques terroristes
contre Israël plus de 40 français sont
morts et trois sont encore en otage à
Gaza à l'initiative de la France le
Hamas fait désormais l'objet d'un régime
de sanction spécifique de l'Union
européenne car oui c'est un groupe
terroriste s'agissant de la situation à
Gaza elle s'aggrave de façon dramatique
la France est totalement mobilisée pour
mettre un terme à cette situation elle
est mobilisée sur un plan humanitaire
déjà ont été déployé 1000 tonnes de
nourriture et d'équipement une aide de
100 millions d'euros pour la population
à civile de Gaza plus de 1000 actes
médicaux ont été réalisés en Égypte sur
le dismut et une coopération étroite
avec la Jordanie complète cet engagement
des enfants palestiniens sont soignés
dans nos hôpitaux grâce à l'action
conjointe du kéorsé et du min ministère
de la Santé la France est également
mobilisée sur le terrain politique en
vue de redonner corps à la solution à
deux états que vous mentionnez madame la
députée et qui est la position
historique de la France mais aussi celle
du droit international c'est justement
l'objet de la réunion du Conseil de
sécurité et la France y a également en
joint le conseil à œuvré pour un cesser
le feu je vous remercie madame la
ministre madame la
députée madame la ministre nous
attendons cette reconnaissance avec
impatience il y a vraiment
urgence je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien petavi pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues ma
question aurait pu être pour la Ministre
chargée des personnes handicapées mais
il n'y en a plus puisque finalement avec
vous tout est une affaire d'argent même
quand il s'agit de dignité je voulais
m'adresser à à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie en avril dernier lors de la
Conférence nationale du handicap le
président de la République a fait une
promesse importante et attendu le
remboursement intégral par l'Assurance
Maladie de tous les fauteuils roulants
ces derniers jours les fabricants
prestataires et associations m'ont
alerté sur les conditions de prise en
charge tarifaire qui leur ont été
présentées il y aurait bien une
augmentation de la base de remboursement
à 2600 € pour les fauteuils manuels et
10 18000 € pour les fauteuils
électriques mais un plafond du même
montant serait instauré nous nous
retrouverions alors dans une situation
ubuesque tous les modèles au-dessus du
plafond ne seraient plus du tout
remboursés un exemple simple mon
fauteuil regardez mon fauteuil monsieur
le ministre il n'est pas spectaculaire
pas extravagant il est juste adapté
léger maniable et surmesure ce fauteuil
coûte aujourd'hui 8000 €. ce n'est pas
un luxe c'est une question d'autonomie
et de dignité avec les nouvelles
conditions de prise en charge mon
fauteuil ne serait plus du tout
remboursé nous l'avons vu avec le PLFSS
votre seule volonté de contenir les
dépenses au détriment de l'autonomie du
bien-être et de la dignité alors que
fait-on que fait-on monsieur le ministre
pour ces personnes qui vont devoir
maintenant payer la totalité du prix du
fauteuil roulant alors qu'il n'y arrivit
déjà pas avec un reste à charge que
fait-on pour ces parents qui vont devoir
continuer à créer des cagnottes
participatives pour espérer financer le
fauteuil de leur enfant que fait-on pour
ces milliers de personnes qui vont
renoncer à un équipement adapté
renonçant ainsi à l'autonomie à sortir à
pratiquer une activité sportive bref à
vivre merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame
Catherine Vautrin ministre du Travail de
la santé des
solidaritésci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Sébastien péavi nous
avons la semaine dernière lors de ma
première venu dans cet hémicycle évoquer
ce sujet extrêmement important vous avez
raison le président de la République a
pris un engagement cet engagement il l'a
pris devant la Conférence nationale du
handicap le sujet c'est celui de
l'autonomie l'engagement du président de
la République c'est le remboursement
intégral c'est l'engagement qu'il a pris
aujourd'hui nous sommes à moment où il y
a une concertation entre les
associations de patients d'une part
d'autre part l'ensemble des fournisseurs
et c'est dans cette concertation que
nous nous devons trouver les réponses et
travailler ensemble sur le sujet c'est
d'ailleurs le sens de l'échange que j'ai
eu avec vous la semaine dernière et je
suis à votre disposition pour que nous
continuion sur le sujet car l'autonomie
des personnes ayant besoin d'un fauteuil
roulant c'est l'une des réponses les
plus concrètes que nous pouvons apporter
à nos itoyen merci beaucoup madame la
ministre s'il vous plaît la parole est à
Monsieur Richard Ramos pour le groupe
démocrate madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues j'associe à ma question mon
collègue Philippe latombe spécialiste du
numérique au Mouvement Démocrate
monsieur le ministre vous avez renforcé
les dispositions permettant à l'état de
se pososer à une opération de rachat
d'actifs stratégiqu d'entreprise
française ces derniers mois
un fleuron est dans la tourmente c'est
le groupe atthos qui emploie plus de
100000 personnes il porte des projets
stratégique d'avenir très important pour
notre pays cela est dramatique car dans
moins de 200 jours le monde entier aura
les yeux rivés sur Paris avec les Jeux
Olympiques or le groupe Athos a été
choisi pour livrer et gérer les
infrastructure numérique de ce grand
événement ainsi que les Jeux Olympiques
paraolympiques la situation tion dans
laquelle se trouve Atos et le résultat
de près de 6 mois d'attentisme alors
qu'un plan de continuité industrielle
est sur la table depuis 6 mois derniers
depuis 6 mois le groupe Athos vient de
nommer son 7e PDG en 4 ans sous la
pression de fonds d'activistes étrangers
ce nouveau PDG américain envisage
désormais une vente à la découpe de
plusieurs activités stratégiques du
groupe l'une à des Allemands l'autre à
des Canadiens on annonce ourd'hi
peut-être à des Américains le plan de
démantèlement aurait pour conséquence
une casse sociale sans précédent avec
6000 emplois menacés juste en France et
près d'un milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en moins sur l'activité
traditionnelle du groupe monsieur le
ministre comment pouvons-nous imaginer
qu'un leader Français puisse se déclarer
en faillite à seulement quelques
semaines des Joos envisagez-vous
monsieur le ministre de protéger les
entreprises françaises et ses salariés
comme le groupe Atos d'appétit
malveillant et d'assurer qu'une
entreprise française qui a des capacités
puisse tenir ses engagements et sauver
ses emploi dans la dans cette république
française je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Prisc evau porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Ramos Bruno Le Maire
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la souveraineté industrielle me
charge de vous répondre étant
effectivement avec le président de la
République en déplacement oui vous avez
raison Athos est une entreprise
stratégique pour la France l'état suit
donc de très près la situation de
l'entreprise et assure que les intérêts
souverains seront respectés nous
n'hésiterons pas à mobiliser les outils
nécessaires notamment le contrôle des
investissements étrangers dans notre
pays en France le code monétaire et
financier soumet en effet à
l'autorisation du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique une prise de
participation importante d'un acteur
étranger sur une entreprise sensible
Atos a besoin d'investisseurs privés et
d'industriel pour se développer dans les
marchés du numérique le rôle de l'État
est donc de protéger nos actifs
essentiels stratégiques ilontt été il le
sont et ils continueront à l'être je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Michel
castellané pour le groupe
lot merci merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le Premier ministre à la suite
des émeutes qui ont succédé au drame de
la prison d'Arles le président de la
République a décidé d'ouvrir un dialogue
de fond avec les élus de la Corse
dialogue qui a été qualifié de processus
de beauau je puis témoigner de
l'engagement du ministre de l'Intérieur
et rendre hommage à sa volonté
d'apporter une réelle réponse à la
question Corse la situation de la Corse
est particulière par sa géographie
certes mais aussi par l'existence
historique d'un peuple sa culture ses
traditions la profondeur du sentiment
d'appartenance qui permis à tant de
femmes et d'hommes de venir partager un
destin commun sur cette île cette
réalité on le sait est difficile à
prendre en compte dans la structure
centralisé d'un état nation comme est
difficile d'ailleurs en cette période de
crise prendre en compte les difficultés
économiques et sociales la culturation
ou la ou la dépossession foncière or on
traite mal à une situation particulière
avec des lois générales l'idée n'est
donc pas de se singularisé par
coquetterie mais de trouver un chemin
institutionnel qui permette de porter le
progrès global que les Corses attendent
depuis de siècles le processus de
beauovau avance péniblement en dépit de
l'engagement de la collectivité de Corse
malgré l'impulsion qu'a voulu lui donner
le président de la République je vous
demande donc Monsieur le Premier
Ministre quel est votre sentiment et
quelle suite vous entendez donner au
processus dont votre gouvernement a la
responsabilité je vous remercie mon
chers collègue la parole est à Monsieur
le Premier
Ministre merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Michel
Castellan le 28 septembre dernier à
l'occasion du 80e anniversaire de la
libération de la Corse à ajacio le
président de la République a pris des
engagements clairs des engagements qui
sont en cohérence avec une nouvelle
approche qu'il avait eu l'occasion
d'exprimer à plusieurs reprises et
notamment pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle monsieur le député ses
engagements je vous le dis de manière
très claire au nom de mon gouvernement
ces engagements nous les
tiendrons nous les tiendrons et d'abord
nous allons poursuivre les travaux
visant à faire apparaître dans la
Constitution la mention de la Corse
d'affirmer au sein d'un article un
article propre la reconnaissance d'une
communauté insulaire historique
linguistique et culturelle c'était un
engagement du Président de la République
évidemment il lit mon gouvernement il y
a ensuite les responsabilités nouvelles
qui seront données à la collectivité de
Corse en tirant les leçons des
insuffisance du statut actuel
concrètement il s'agit de pouvoir
adapter les règles et même les loi là
encore le président a marqué une
ambition nouvelle et forte nous pouvons
si les élus de Corse le décident bâtir
une forme d'autonomie à la Corse
c'est-à-dire une autonomie pour l'île et
dans la République le dialogue a
commencé je lis évidemment et je prends
connaissance des prises de position des
uns et des autres par voie de presse ou
dans le dialogue avec mes ministres mais
le dialogue se poursuit et le dialogue
va se poursuivre enfin nous devons
avancer ensemble autour de bien d'aut re
défi mieux enseigner le corse créer un
service public de l'enseignement qui
favorise le bilinguisme et en tant que
ministre de l'Éducation nationales dans
mes fonctions précédentes j'ai eu
l'occasion évidemment de travailler sur
cette question nous avons vous le savez
un recteur très dynamique sur ce sujet
de l'enseignement public du corse
répondre au défis immobiliers sur l'île
créer une métropole pour ajaaco
renforcer la chambre des territoires
revoir le mode de scrutin pour les
élections territoriales toutes ces
pistes elles sont discutées par
l'ensemble des formations politiques
insulaires elles doivent être être
approfondi dans une logique de consensus
alors maintenant comment avancer le
président de la République a ainsi
invité les responsables politique Corse
à consolider un accord dans les 6 mois
et dans cet état d'esprit le ministre de
l'Intérieur se rendra en Corse début
février pour faire un point d'étape
recueillir la contribution de l'ensemble
des acteurs sur cette base mon
gouvernement poursuivra ses travaux en
vue de proposer au Parlement les textes
constitutionnels et organiques
nécessaires comme le président de la
République la appeler il nous faut bâtir
un nouveau modèle qui soit pleinement
Corse celui de la Corse dans la
République celui d'une autonomie qui
permette de construire un avenir
ensemble et avec l'engagement de l'État
je vous remercie monsieur
Castellani merci merci monsieur le
Premier ministre nous prenons Act avec
plaisir de de votre intervention qui est
importante nous espérons tous que le
processus marquera une étape décisive
dans l'histoire de de la Corse
contemporaine je voudrais également
ajouter que qu'il sera important que
Bastia que vous n'avez pas cité que
Bastia qui a été totalement ignoré par
un centralisme régional exacerber B
trouve enfin une place qui doit lui
revenir dans la vie politique
institutionnelle de la Corse et moi
j'espère que vous vous emploirez que
vous prendez conscience de cette
situation que vous emploerez à corriger
ce déséquilibre dommageable je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon chers
collègue la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue elle reprendra à 15h sur le
projet de loi constitutionnel relatif à
la liberté de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse